how do you create consistent content
when you have a full-time job how do you
get it all done to work all day and
spend your energy all day at work and to
get home and to want to work on your
side hustle an uncommon life requires
uncommon choices and habits this is
possible and here's how we're gonna do
it
in this episode of the think media
podcast I want to be sharing some
lessons I've learned while I was working
40 hours plus per week doing a job while
also doing YouTube on the side and how
do you get it all done and how do you
stay consistent I also want to share
with you the three lists that every
Creator needs
so that you can ultimately boost your
pre productivity and get the right
things done but if we are meeting
recently my name is Sean Cannell and
I've now been doing YouTube started our
think media channel 13 years ago I
started the first Channel that I did for
my church in a small town an hour north
of Seattle 16 years ago and I started
video three years or four years before
that so I've been doing video for 20
years so for about eight years I was
doing YouTube on the side while having
different jobs and I've had a job
waiting tables at Red Robin which is a
burger restaurant I've worked on
different Church staffs and different
roles part-time quarter time helping out
in youth mainly video eventually a
full-time director of communications I
was a campus Pastor for a year and a
half and the majority of that time I was
doing a side hustle I was doing
freelance work sometimes on the side and
I was also doing YouTube content on the
side so I've learned a lot I've made
more mistakes than anybody lots of
lessons that I think can be helpful to
you in any season of life and I think
one other thing to know is I recently
had children so now I've been learning
new things for the season of life I'm in
with my wife Sonia of 17 years got a two
and a half year old we've got a
seven month old and we are in a whole
different season where our company now
has multiple team members helping
um and so we had kids in a whole
different season you gotta always
contextualize this information to your
own season but for the majority of time
our schedule was super packed but we had
no kids so of course as we get into
these tips I think you've got to be
thinking about what is your unique
circumstance right of course it's a
little bit different if you got a lot of
kids are you dual income single parent
and so we all face different challenges
but I promise you that if you apply
these four tips and these tactics you
are going to get more done with less
stress and ultimately have greater peace
of mind and be able to stay consistent
on YouTube because I want to encourage
you it is possible and that's maybe the
first big belief this is possible it's
not gonna be easy but it is possible and
here's how we're gonna do it number one
Define your priorities the first step
and this is actually kind of an
interactive episode that's maybe worth
of course if you're driving you can just
kind of listen and think about it but if
you have a chance to even open up a
note-taking app on your phone or pull
out a piece of paper really engaging
with this content can help you get some
better results because what are your
priorities what are your what are your
priorities and what are your core
responsibilities the first thing to
probably write down is not only just
what you wish your priorities were but
if you're a parent keeping those guys
alive is probably one of the core
responsibilities
you can't miss that if you know what
your expenses are monthly
not what you're inflated
overspending spending more than you make
expenses but what your core expenses are
you're like at this point I gotta stick
with this job because my job is solid so
I need to I can't do not lose that job
do not lose with spouse do not lose like
who's your no who's the who's the list
of people you got to show up for the
list of the responsibilities you got to
show up for the the do not disappoint
list I actually that was one thing I
learned recently who's my do not
disappoint list because I'm going to
disappoint everybody
um well I'm gonna disappoint a lot of
people but I if I I would much rather
disappoint the internet I would much
rather disappoint the think media
podcast Community if it meant that I
wasn't disappointing my spouse I don't
want to disappoint my spouse and my kids
but like make you happy now I do want
you to be happy and I thank you for
being here but there's an order to this
I don't want to disappoint God so I want
to think about okay what are my core
responsibilities what are my core
response uh priorities and that's
important for you to write down and just
the essentials and then who do you need
to communicate your priorities to as
well do you need to communicate your
priorities to a boss or to a spouse like
for example this very unique situation
but when I was getting hired in 2011 and
applying at a church in Las Vegas called
The Church LV I actually had two YouTube
channels at the time I actually had
three too much by the way horrible idea
but I had Clear Vision media my video
production business and I was still
chipping away at some freelance video
work and I'd upload those projects there
2011. I have this channel called think
International which was a faith-based
channel we ended up posting about 250
videos screw to 10 000 subscribers it's
still just sitting there on the YouTube
abandoned but I started with my friend
Jeff Morse that channel was active at
the time to to a certain extent and I
had think media which was semi-active as
well said these three YouTube channels
so I remember meeting with Benny Perez
the lead pastor of this church who was
considering hiring me and I had applied
for this job and I said hey is it going
to be okay I'm gonna honor my job but I
do have some pre-existing projects and I
actually negotiated which you can't it's
probably hard to do this like if you
already have a job because you're
already in it now you're like hey could
I get like more time but I said hey if I
do a good job and I really crush it and
you're happy and I check with you
um I have this thing called think
International that was kind of the main
focus would I be able to maybe do a
couple things a year it is and that was
very related to our me as a director of
communications at the church here's my
point I was enrolling people around me
in my priorities as well which could be
helpful right communicating your
priorities who do you need to
communicate your priorities to your
spouse to do you agree with your spouse
do people in your world know what your
priorities are but here's the key if
you're saying Sean I want to create
consistent content is that on your list
of priorities
and let me challenge you that if you
have 10 priorities you have no
priorities if you have like five
priorities you have no priorities at
this season of Life at this exact moment
my three priorities are family my health
and think media the business I'm in a
what feels like a very blessed but a
very challenging season two young kids
and so and then Jesus at the center of
it all so my family I can't lose I don't
want to lose my family I want to honor
my kids I'm we all are blessed to be
able to be thoughtful but I'm empathetic
if you've got if you have to do like
three jobs right now single parent like
it could be absolutely insane I have the
decision to put my priorities in order
so it's like okay family's on the
calendar okay my health I've got some
chronic pain I've got some chronic
health challenges pain in my arms and
wrists nerve entrapment needing to do
some physical therapy doing some
different supplements and things so I'm
saying help in this season health is a
priority and then think media and I'm
like I gotta keep Snow piercer on the
tracks Niche reference but if you know
you know and so how do we keep Snow
piercer on the tracks which is yes
YouTube but for me it would be a bigger
priority of keep the business going
stay in business
stay put positive on the p l what are
your priorities I have found that a lot
of people haven't defined those they
probably are trying to do too many
things in too many seasons and if you
would say that okay you know maybe
family or maybe it's no kids and if it's
no kids no spouse and you're not dating
you got a whole nother level of
availability on your schedule or
whatever so you might say my work
stay healthy and build my YouTube side
hustle build my online business and then
you also go but it's also like get
amazing at Motocross and that has
nothing to do with your YouTube channel
it might be the season that that's they
can't do that like learn 14 new
instruments you know like you just can't
say that everything's a priority number
one Define your priorities number two do
a Time audit and review of your calendar
I'm about to step into your business
if you don't mind so your calendar is
the ultimate scorecard of your
priorities and if I was to look back
over your calendar last week the week
before over the last month
it your calendar would reveal your
priorities to me here's the problem if
you've defined your priorities in number
one and now we look at your calendar is
your calendar really lined up with your
priorities if you've got more Netflix on
your calendar than you do working on
your YouTube channel
then maybe your kids and your goals and
your YouTube channel are not fully being
aligned with your priorities if and
these are this is the Insidious one if
you're just scrolling in online shopping
for 45 minutes here for stuff you don't
need and if you're just scrolling
randomly on your phone over here what's
actually happening in your time during
the day
is chipping away at your priorities and
really the possibilities that exist
inside of your world right now your
calendar right now your time right now
your calendar is the scorecard of your
priorities and this one hurts this hurts
for everybody so if you're like bro
relax even when I look at mine like this
is a tough one but it's it's where we
start to understand that
this is possible almost in any season
you can also stay consistent on YouTube
but it just takes discipline it takes
focus and let's just consider what's
possible in a week okay we all have 24
hours a day and 168 hours a week if you
spend 40 hours a week at work that's
eight hours per day if you spend 56
hours sleeping that's eight hours per
night now probably you might go I don't
even sleep that much I have extra time
you might
or it's actually negative because your
energy isn't quite right I actually
thinking whatever your body needs seven
to eight new new research says like the
majority of people there's like less
than one percent have like this genetic
thing where you can really do well on
like three or four but like chances are
to be at your best and create your best
content and all of that like you really
want to be at eight hours per night or
seven or eight a night so let's just say
40 hours at work 56 hours sleeping do
you have a commute 1.5 hours a day total
that would be 7.5 hours a week or do you
work remote do you work from home do you
not have a commute we either just
regained almost eight hours because you
don't commute or if you do could you
turn your commute into when you learn
one of our video ranking Academy
students Jacqueline from the wild
Floridian has a commute and she has
crushed all of her learning modules
inside of our online course because she
does it while she's commuting so she's
actually redeemed that time as it
relates to being consistent on you
YouTube and learning okay if we add on
eating for 21 hours that'd be one and a
half hours a day of eating maybe you eat
longer than that but it's just a quick
breakfast a quick lunch sit down for
dinner
um five hours a week on chores that's an
hour a day and cleaning five hours a
week on working out and exercise that is
only 134.5 hours
so that leaves everything we just
described 33.5 hours left for whatever
you want to fill it with well Sean I got
kids okay family
well Sean I want to do YouTube we can
put YouTube in there I do want some
sports or entertainment or gaming like
there's a lot of other things you could
fill in there
but here's the real numbers
did you know that the average person
spends two hours and 27 minutes on
social media every day
that's almost 16 hours per week so
inside of our program we teach What's
called the five hour YouTube Work week
but ultimately like if you had 16 extra
hours that we could find you could be
consistent on YouTube and that's just
from not scrolling on social media now
here's what Forbes discovered Americans
spent on average more than 1 300 hours
on social media last year so what could
you do with 1300 hours in your year
towards building your side projects
building your side house so building
your online business gen Z spends nine
hours a day on social media and on their
phones while all of this could be
shocking and scary this is me
challenging you to say like oh Sean
full-time job how do I stay consistent
on YouTube
the time is probably there
it's just how disciplined are we and I
get it even if we if we refined it all
the way down I pretty much promise you
that almost anybody listening to this
whether on the YouTube channel on one of
the audio platforms friend we could find
five six seven eight hours in your week
at least and chances are we could
probably find closer to 16. but Sean
I've got to play the new Harry Potter
game at least a few hours a day but Sean
I've got to watch my shows as a way of
unwinding well that's fine you got to do
whatever you want and I'm not trying to
talk you out of any of that stuff I'm
just saying what's your goal what are
you trying to achieve what's on your
priority list for this season what are
you willing to sacrifice the time is
there so doing a Time audit so number
one what are your actual priorities
number two time audit and review your
calendar
number three and here we go these are
the three lists we all need so I want
you to make three lists
number one what are your mission
critical tasks
number two what are your important but
not critical tasks and number three what
are your not important tasks or
activities that you've been doing I
Define my priorities back to my story I
had to honor my job at the church LV so
it's like I I have to do that right and
I also have to honor my wife
you know stay married like you know like
that's a priority for me like do you
know like uh like take care of that
responsibility build my business like
these uh these days are you know build
my businesses on there so in the early
days of think media when I would put on
the mission critical tasks though
because you you could go what are your
priorities but then also what are the
mission critical tasks for your YouTube
channel versus what are the mission
critical tasks that are less important
when it comes to your online business or
your YouTube channel so for example I
would say okay well Mission critical
would be quality content like I need to
put out at least one piece of content a
week or not even but I need to put out
quality content over a year's time
when people come to the channel they
need to see something good that means
it's not even rushed too that I need
enough space or margin or time to make
something worthwhile if I can find 16
hours by just cutting down social media
usage then I'm investing some of that 16
hours into making quality content
now also Mission critical skill building
and study
from
really
2007 a little bit before that and it
really ramped up in 2010
I started to aggressively invest in
skill building I mean reading listening
to audio programs I mean even back I
remember back in 2010 I purchased this
like how to be a better Communicator
course off eBay that was a bunch of CDs
from like Chris Weidner and John Maxwell
like I've been living the life of
personal growth personal development and
learning the skill sets necessary for
this exact career for over a decade
um voraciously intentionally it's part
of the mission critical activities I've
attended events and bought plane tickets
to go learn about like how do you also
build a bigger business around not just
a YouTube channel and so I'm like what
is even uh you know online marketing and
email marketing and like how do you and
then early days how do you edit video I
remember studying still motion I don't
even know if they're still around how to
use my DSLR how to get smoother shots
frame rates editing codecs studying
skill building so what are the mission
critical tasks another one was ranking
videos ranking videos was a mission
critical task and in the early days of
think media this is maybe the whole key
of this podcast this is the big key so
lean in for this Sean when I have a
full-time job and eventually I want to
quit my full-time job what is the best
path to get out of that
I saw the opportunity for ranking videos
early on today it's and since you know
we have an academy called video ranking
Academy but here's the basic premise
let's say it's 2014. so I'm doing this
think media starts I'm working at the
church a church in Las Vegas and I'm
probably working 40 plus hours a week
just right around there right full-time
salary maybe a little bit more
especially too because I think we only
had one day off we had like a day and a
half off because we had a Saturday night
service and then we had like Sunday and
sometimes we had a Sunday night service
and then you went back in the office
Monday Tuesday Wednesday and Friday was
actually off you had like a day and a
half off like Friday and half a Saturday
and so not a lot of time although you
have evenings and like if you're not
gaming you could be working on your site
like whatever and so what I understood
was okay YouTube's a search engine if I
make a video that's quality that I don't
just create this week with my extra time
but that keeps getting views for the
coming weeks months and is connected to
a passive income stream then eventually
little by little my channel will keep
growing not because I have to post a
video every week but it'll grow because
I've created a library of ranked videos
we don't have time to go into that but
like if you want more on that and you
haven't seen our free class at
thinkmasterclass.com a breakdown what is
Reiki videos how do you do it and
that'll help you because again when time
is short and you've got a full-time job
you're trying to do things today that
get you more time and money tomorrow
even if it's little by little because
then eventually I was making three four
five hundred dollars a month when I took
the leap to full time and then I was
able to close that Gap because I had
built a library of ranked videos I had
built up a channel that was growing even
if it was slow it was growing because I
posted a video today that still got
videos months later and even years later
and so in those early days and I know we
encourage you to post one video a week
like you got to post one video a week
and I know these days people post smoke
more because of shorts and all this
other stuff but the the early days of
think media was
one video this week a video next week no
videos for three weeks three videos a
week for three weeks in summer
two weeks with no videos it was a lot
more like that and so I think that's
just my story is that like yeah like
it's got to be every Tuesday and I like
that discipline and whatnot and and
these days it's more like what we're
doing at think media but just be
consistent and consistent sometimes is
an exact math like every Tuesday it just
means like constantly making deposits in
your YouTube Bank constantly making
uploads that are quality so Mission
critical quality content Mission
critical skill building and study
Mission critical ranking videos
important but not Mission critical
here's your second list
now on that list
could could be again in fact I would
almost say like you have your YouTube
channel so it's really like six lists
because a lot of the time you're going
to recover is in your personal life and
your personal choices and your personal
decisions so it's like what's Mission
critical make sure the kids are fed the
other day you know that's I always joke
like Sony will come home and she'll be
like have you fed our son is he eating
like goldfish and sugar-filled fruit
bars while you're watching TV and we are
having them do no screen time I'm like
honey relax okay I'm doing my best here
probably not I I deserve every critical
work and you know uh feed the kids
hopefully something healthy
um you know like put them to bed make
sure they're safe certain like that's
Mission critical um important but not
Mission critical is you know get
distracted in the Wormhole of conspiracy
theories on the internet and and just go
down some weird rabbit hole on YouTube
for 90 minutes uh learning about Ancient
Aliens and uh watching bizarre Joe Logan
conversations like it was that mission
critical it might not have been Mission
critical and I might have I look back
and I'm like wow that that 90 minutes
um I will never get that back you know
so there's like personal what's
personally Mission critical
personally important but not Mission
critical
and then what's absolutely a waste of
time and then in your YouTube channel
Mission critical quality content skill
building Reiki videos important but not
Mission critical other social media
platforms it might not be Mission
critical and I would argue it isn't that
you be on every social media platform
this is for you to decide and do some
critical thinking for yourself oh Sean
you wouldn't believe all of the
connections I'm making on Instagram DMS
okay Rebecca relax like that works for
you like that's great but like a lot of
people get distracted by trying to be on
all these platforms one of my biggest
pet peeves is people who are super
consistent on their Facebook page like
their Facebook business page and there
is zero engagement like literally like
every single time they post there's zero
likes zero comments and as a side note
Facebook reels especially are blowing up
right now and there's kind of an
algorithmic reach Revival in relation to
Facebook reach but that's probably a
distraction for you unless you have some
kind of workflow of consistent vertical
video and the punch line is I see people
that actually have I don't know I don't
know if it's just because they're using
social media automation or like they're
like okay when I'm done with content
what I do is I go through a checklist
and I post it everywhere well why you
posted on your Facebook fan page we can
look back over the past six weeks
there's literally zero I mean even if
you've got some results like oh cool it
like led to every once in a while a
couple people saw it so it's like
measuring the things that like are not
moving the needle a great researched
video that is then thoughtfully designed
following the perfect video recipe that
then ranks in search that is really
optimized in the description with great
links to a passive income stream like
affiliate marketing is Mission critical
and instead of doing something else I'd
rather do that again I'd rather do
quality content skill building and
ranking videos over and over and over
again than posting on other social media
platforms unless I could directly
attribute that to earning money why
because you need money for the mission
because the whole point of this whole
podcast is eventually you could go
part-time at your job or quit your job
and you need a financially close that
bridge so any activity that's maybe
important but not Mission critical
should you should seriously consider not
doing it how about sorting your email or
your junk mail maybe just love oh I
gotta delete these junk mail oh look is
this a brand deal that's interesting I
don't know this might just be a scam
probably is if you're a small YouTube
channel yes there's opportunities for
micro influencers and Nano influencers
and brands are paying them however
there's also a lot of scams and so a lot
of people will email you and be like hey
give us some money we'll send you some
sunglasses we want to sponsor you and
they won't or like they're actually just
trying to like there's just different
stuff happening here's my point if you
can say it's Mission critical and it's
working that's one thing but if you're
just going through your email and then
getting distracted with some online
shopping and then you know going through
your junk and seeing Oh there's a new
article about the crater economy and
like that's it's kind of all cool but
like who care get back to the main
mission endlessly scrolling over
learning
skill building and learning is key but
over learning because you take your 16
hours and all you do is learn during the
16 when you should probably learn during
like four create videos for like five
optimize and and kind of promote and do
some admin stuff for the other three or
four and then do it again every week and
instead of just wasting 16 hours on a
bunch of random stuff use it on Mission
critical stuff and you know my friend
Rory Vaden wrote a book called
procrastinate on purpose I think one of
the keys for me getting through the
season of full-time job to full-time
YouTube Creator was procrastinating on
purpose was at some level probably to
the frustration of friends and family
members many who would probably say this
is just how you are based on your
personality but was just like literally
getting clear on the one two three four
priorities in my life and ignoring
everything else which is tough I mean
that's up to you and it's just like but
it's like people are texting you people
are asking for things people are
emailing things like just ignoring it
people are reaching out interruptions
are happening just ignoring it like
there's something about procrastinating
and here's what Rory Vader discovered
you're procrastinating on purpose your
your purpose for you what's funny about
that book I should have it back on the
podcast is ranking videos is exactly the
type of activity that he prescribes in
the book what can I do his this is like
his time multiplier formula what can I
do today that gives me more time
tomorrow like how could I do activities
today creating quality content that pays
me tomorrow so that I can keep buying
back my time keep multiplying my time
that means I'm ignoring stuff that
doesn't do that so it's kind of like if
I'm not if it's not if it's not making
me passive income and I'm not ranking
videos I'm not doing it so today
big key at think media we do all kinds
of vertical video we do Tick Tock we do
reels we do Pinterest vertical video
Yeah well I've got a whole base of
ranked videos that pay the bills
so I'm expanding the Brand's expanding
you should not be imitating this is
probably another tip you should not be
imitating the activities of a Creator
like me
in this season you should be imitating
the activities of a Creator like me back
when I had the full-time job I'm just
going to do what Sean's doing well
Sean's got 20 people helping him and so
it's not that this this is just as
possible because the pessimist and
Senate goes oh that there's the secret
no no no no bro relax Trevor the
Ultimate key is that I had certain
activities and a level of discipline
when I was by myself the only person
working on this editing shooting doing
all the things and I had to
procrastinate on purpose and ignore
anything that wasn't Mission critical
and then finally your final list and you
may have the personal version and then
the YouTube version what's just not
important at all it's not even important
just not Mission critical it's like not
even important at all a lot of people do
tasks that are just an absolute waste of
your time for example a dead Facebook
page or just a Facebook page that isn't
active even worse back to the pet peeve
people go the only thing on their
Facebook feed this is also why it's not
working is links to their YouTube video
well the reach is so throttled there's
literally zero likes and zero comments
and you just do it as like a discipline
that activity has a net neg it's just
not important at all especially right
now but even more so this could be TV
partying video games procrastinating
Leisure it could be people that steal
your energy and weaken your vision like
just
things that are not going to help you
get towards your goals and this is the
law of sacrifice you got to give up to
go up those who figure this out it's
possible but it is it's not that it's
easy it does take discipline it's a
whole other person I wanna I wanna
encourage you it takes a whole lot of
energy and grit to work all day and
spend your energy all day at work and to
get home and to want to work on your
side hustle it's freaking it's so hard
you got to reset your energy get into
the Zone take a break eat dinner and get
back to the grind and do it over and
over and over again it's hard but it is
possible and so the level of scrupulous
detail you want to have in eliminating
things from your schedule what's Mission
critical what's important but not
Mission critical and what's not
important and then number four is I want
to encourage you to do it messy and
embrace your season you got to do it
messy that's why I go back it's like
well Sean will you just perfectly
disciplined during the season when you
had the full-time job at the church and
you were building think media no like
not at all I would still go home and
like get distracted I would still
probably should have posted every week
but got distracted by other things and
didn't well like you gotta just do it
messy and do your best like keep putting
videos in the YouTube bank and really
just Embrace gray space productivity
like yes it means needs discipline and
yes we got to do all this stuff but also
like if you have a bad week or a bad
month just get back on it and embrace
your season because I mentioned this at
the beginning but an advantage we had
and partly because of some health
challenges and I won't go into that
story now with my wife's Health seasons
of life we did not have kids until later
in life that was partly an advantage
because no kids meant that besides like
making sure our marriage was good and
honoring work it was like I could work
on my side hustle and it was my choice
of what to do with my other time fast
forward to today with its two little
boys mornings and evenings are a
dumpster fire like we just you don't
know what you're gonna get like and
what's interesting though is I will wake
up and sometimes John Steven and Sean
Bradley will sleep in
uh nice and late and I'm like dude my
morning routine was Bliss like I got up
read my Bible like did some stuff got
open up a Google doc plan a video and
then sometimes I'm getting up and I'm
and I'm like why are these kids up and
they're up at 5 45 your whole morning so
so you make your plans but your plan's
got to be flexible blessed are the
flexible those who Bend and don't break
right now evenings as well last night
was insane last night I was able to we
put the kids down Sean Bradley goes down
at 7 30. Sonia and Sean and John Stephen
went down at like 7 45 and so I
recaptured from 7 45 to 10 30 where I
actually focused on health stuff
stretching and then I did
um
ultimately read a book decisive crushed
a couple chapters in a book back to that
skill building and study and planned a
little bit for today on our podcast
shoot
so you're doing your best because that
was some time that I S that I seized
that I really could have lately I've
been into Starcraft too Mel on the think
media team and not playing Starcraft 2
by the way which is a really old
real-time strategy game not playing it
but watching it watching Elite Level Pro
level players
um play the game and these are like 45
minute best of three matches so I can I
can give you a good 45 minutes I can
spend a good 60 minutes just watching
Starcraft 2. here's the key last night I
felt the pull
okay are you gonna read the book that
you're committed to finishing to keep
building up your skills or are you just
gonna zone out and watch Starcraft got
some self-awareness maybe needed some
time to take a break it's all good I've
probably watched 30 hours of Starcraft
this year who knows you know like
whatever but last night I was like okay
especially because I can actually bounce
my uh you know son or whatever and maybe
do some other stuff we watch blippi
together but I when I have that
opportunity I seized it what's the
opportunity on your schedule you're in a
certain season but when the day goes
your way great you got the video out if
it doesn't great do it next time that
you can do it messy embrace your season
I want to encourage you it is possible I
want to encourage you you have more time
than you realize I want to encourage you
that your next level will be accessed by
your next level of discipline and I know
that you don't expect me to be cursing
on a podcast like this and I hate to say
the d word but you need discipline and
I'm sorry I know like if kids are around
cover their ears I know it's a word that
we don't like but like we need
discipline and your next level of
breakthrough is going to be accessed on
your next level of discipline and I
believe if you see it's possible see the
opportunity on your calendar and get
disciplined with your time make the
three lists knowing that an uncommon
life requires uncommon choices and
habits Sean this all sounds ridiculous
why is this so intense man just relax
like no no I get it this is your choice
you don't have to do any of this stuff
but if you have the audacity to say man
I want to go full time on YouTube create
a passive income I want to build a life
and a future on my around my dreams I
Want To Be My Own Boss I want to impact
the world I want to be a part of
arguably one of the greatest careers and
opportunities right now being in this
crater economy then you count the cost
and then you pay the price of the law of
sacrifice the an uncommon life requires
uncommon choices and habits and if you
want the life that others don't have you
have to do what others won't do my name
is Sean Cannell rhymes with YouTube
channel thanks for listening to the
think media podcast and I can't wait to
connect with you in a future episode